Portanto, a questão clicker que eu quero
propor para vocês agora é...
Ah, droga! Isto diz votação fechada.
Pronto, votação aberta.
"Você se compromete a desligar a
internet completamente?"...
pressione 1.
"Você se compromete a limitar o uso
da internet de alguma forma?"
Ou seja, você mantém a internet, mas
promete não checar Facebook
ou jogar Angry Birds ou ir
às compras na Zappos
ou qualquer outra coisa
indulgente que você faz na rede.
Se esse é o seu caso, pressione 2.
"Você não marcou nenhuma restrição
no uso da internet na aula,
mas tem um computador?"
Se assim for, pressione 3.
Ou tudo isso não se aplica ao seu caso,
já que você usa lápis
e papel na aula?
OK. O contador de tempo talvez
já era para estar na regressiva...
mas não, eu tenho de
tagarelar por 28 segundos.
Então, vamos lá.
Esta é a situação... eu li os
artigos e a minha sensação
– não sei se era uma
amostra aleatória –
é que cerca de 2/3 dos alunos
estão comprometidos em desligar
a internet totalmente,
cerca de 1/4 está comprometido
com a restrição parcial
e uma porcentagem muito
pequena está comprometida
com a não restrição do
uso da internet.
OK. O slide deve aparecer
em 1 segundo...
Sim. OK.
Portanto, 43% dos alunos desta sala
fizeram um pré-compromisso na
forma de uma promessa.
Isso se tornou um pré-compromisso
porque vocês escreveram.
Somente pensar não faz disso
um pré-compromisso.
Mas vocês agiram num momento em
que se sentiram relaxados,
calmos e sensatos, e
tomaram uma decisão
que está vinculada ao futuro de vocês.
E outros 16% de vocês
não definiram uma linha clara em
desligar a internet completamente,
mas tentaram colocar em prática algum
tipo de restrição intermediária.
Agora, a minha próxima pergunta é
se vocês se corromperam.
20 segundos.
"1: Em nenhum momento. Nunca."
"2: Apenas 1 ou 2 vezes."
"3: Mmm, bem, algumas vezes,
mas eu estou tentando."
Ou "4: Sim, eu estou jogando
Sparkle HD Lite no meu iPad
durante as aulas."
Vamos ver os números que saem.
OK. Então, temos de ir...
eles não aparecem automaticamente.
Arrá! Então, 56% de vocês...
Excelente.
56% de vocês, afinal,
não se corromperam.
Mas observem que a metade se
viu incapaz de cumprir
o compromisso que foi feito
e que foi interiorizado nas
suas consciências com o
sentido de reforçar a ideia de que
vocês tinham um compromisso.
Acontece que, para muitas pessoas,
comprometer-se apenas
mentalmente é insuficiente
para elas estarem nesta
categoria "em nenhum momento".
Para elas... que terminam aqui,
aqui ou mesmo aqui...
colocar em funcionamento algum
tipo de restrição externa
acaba sendo útil.
O The New York Times publicou uma
matéria na semana passada
sobre algo chamado
"preservativos de telefone",
cujo slogan é: "Feche, sele e
guarde no seu bolso".
A ideia é que você
pegue o seu celular,
coloque neste pequeno saco plástico e,
enquanto estiver dirigindo,
não tenha acesso a ele.
Um dos alunos desta classe – vocês vão
ter acesso a isso num slide –
me enviou um link de um
programa de computador
que é basicamente um
preservativo de computador,
um "feche, sele e guarde no seu
bolso" para o acesso à internet.
Ele desliga o acesso à internet
por um determinado tempo.
Mas para quem sente que precisa de
algum tipo de reforço externo,
mas não está preparado para usar
o bloqueio da internet,
eu pensei em oferecer algo que irá
ajudá-los a manter o compromisso,
usando duas coisas que
aprendemos na semana passada.
Uma delas é que, quando há
olhos na sua frente,
você sente o olhar do
mundo sobre você.
E a outra é que, quando há uma
espécie de reforço social
por seus semelhantes, é mais
fácil se ater a um plano.
Portanto, não é só porque sobraram
do bar mitzvah do meu filho
mais velho... eu tenho adesivos de
smiley para distribuir entre vocês.
E, se você quiser, pode colocar um
adesivo vermelho ou laranja
no seu computador,
caso esteja comprometido com "sem
internet" durante a aula.
Ele servirá como lembrete e para
mostrar a seus colegas.
E um adesivo verde ou azul no
seu computador se você
está comprometido com o uso limitado
da internet durante a aula.
Existem 720 adesivos, eles
não vão terminar.
Vocês podem pegar uma
pequena quantidade
e as pessoas vão passando
para as outras,
colando-os ou não.
Não estamos nada mal.
Eles estavam na minha mesa desde o
bar mitzvah, em outubro,
e eu pensei: com isso, nós
podemos salientar
4 coisas de uma só vez numa aula.
Na verdade, podem ser 5, porque a
questão da autorregulação,
de fato, é a questão fundamental
no contexto do material lido para hoje.
Eu quero pedir desculpas,
porque a aula de hoje é,
em geral, sobre os "caras
mortos na terça".
Eu vou percorrer detalhadamente
alguns argumentos de Platão e,
em seguida, alguns
argumentos de Aristóteles.
Mas a minha esperança é
que, ao fazer isso,
eu consiga fornecer um quadro
que permitirá a vocês,
quando voltarem para as leituras,
talvez na hora de escrever os artigos,
verem como esses textos se
tornaram acessíveis.
Como vocês se lembram, Platão
sugeriu que a nossa alma
pode ser entendida como tendo 3 partes.
Temos uma parte racional,
que ele representa às vezes
como um ser humano,
às vezes como um cocheiro.
Temos uma parte chamada de espírito,
que ele representa às vezes como
um cavalo cooperativo,
às vezes como um leão.
E temos, além disso, uma
parte apetitiva,
que ele representa às vezes
como um cavalo selvagem
e às vezes como a besta de
várias cabeças.
A sugestão de Platão é que um
certo tipo de bem-estar
está disponível se conseguimos
alinhar essas partes.
Ele diz que o homem não pode
permitir que as 3 partes
usurpem reciprocamente as
suas funções.
Ele deve assumir o comando de si
mesmo, disciplinar-se
e harmonizar as 3 partes de si
mesmo como 3 notas limitantes
numa escala musical.
"E de múltiplo que era
– de múltiplo que você é,
puxado em 2 direções,
puxado na direção de manter
a internet desligada
e na direção de checar a sua
página do Facebook...
Puxado na direção de ir à biblioteca
e fazer a sua lição de casa
e na direção de sair com os amigos
para conversar...
"de múltiplo que era –
puxado na direção
do que a razão diz para você fazer
e puxado na direção do que o espírito ou
apetite diz para você fazer –
"... se transforme em absolutamente
um, moderado e harmonioso".
O ideal platônico da alma bem
estruturada é o que está regulado
pela razão, onde espírito e apetite
são submetidos ao mandato da razão.
Agora, o que eu quero fazer com
vocês é, basicamente,
um resumo de 30 segundos –
bem, de 5 minutos –
do enredo dos Livros II, III , IV e IX
de A República de Platão.
OK? Portanto, a história é a seguinte:
Platão está tentando nos dizer
como é a alma humana.
E em homenagem ao clima, vamos
representar o ser humano assim:
Ele aponta, como eu acabei de mencionar,
que a alma humana tem 3 partes.
Tem uma parte racional, uma
parte espirituosa
e uma parte que está cheia de apetite.
E você pode ver o ser humano, o leão
e a besta de várias cabeças
na famosa imagem de Platão.
Mas para entender o que é
bom para o ser humano,
Sócrates sugere, no final da
discussão do Livro II,
lido para a última aula,
que a melhor maneira de
entender o que é bom
para o ser humano tripartido é
pensar sobre o que seria bom
para uma cidade que está
estruturada da mesma forma.
Que estruturas da sociedade podem
ajudar a compreender coisas
sobre as estruturas internas
dos seres humanos?
Ele propõe a famosa
analogia da cidade-estado,
em que a parte da alma correspondente
a que ele chama de apetite
são os cidadãos, chamados
de trabalhadores,
ou as pessoas que fazem o
trabalho cotidiano da cidade
e que satisfazem a sua alegria e prazer
nos prazeres do corpo e do apetite.
Há os soldados, aqueles que
defendem a cidade
e servem como defensores no
contexto militar,
motivados pela honra.
E, além disso, há os
filósofos ou tutores,
aqueles que vivem a vida da mente.
E você vai descobrir quem vai
acabar no topo nesta história.
A ideia é que, a fim de compreender
as 4 virtudes cardeais gregas
no contexto do indivíduo,
seremos auxiliados pensando
sobre onde essas virtudes são
encontradas na cidade.
E, então, podemos mapear o que
foi aprendido olhando
para o problema em grande escala,
no contexto da sociedade.
Podemos mapear isso no contexto da
pequena escala do problema,
o indivíduo.
O Sócrates de Platão aponta que
há 4 virtudes cardeais
e você as conhece pela
leitura realizada.
A primeira delas é a sabedoria.
E a sabedoria da cidade e do indivíduo
se encontra na parte racional.
OK. Eles deveriam estar...
Aí está, a coragem.
E a coragem de uma cidade
ou de um indivíduo
pode ser encontrada no seu espírito.
Eles estão dançando...
E há 2 virtudes... a distinção
entre o que é importante
em alguns contextos, mas
não para os nossos...
elas são as virtudes da
moderação e da justiça.
E a sugestão aqui é que, assim
como uma cidade é moderada
e justa quando as relações entre
as pessoas são adequadas,
um indivíduo é moderado ou justo
quando as relações entre as suas
partes são adequadas e próprias.
Ou seja, moderação e justiça envolvem
um certo tipo de harmonia
entre as partes.
Então esta é a imagem platônica.
E acontece que esta é a
resposta de Platão
– a resposta de Platão na
voz de Sócrates –
para o desafio que Glauco propôs
na metade do Livro II.
Vocês se lembram que, no
início do Livro II,
foi dada uma distinção de 3
vias sobre os bens.
Fomos informados de que havia
coisas que são intrinsecamente
valiosas, em si mesmas.
Coisas que são
instrumentalmente
valiosas,
para os bens que elas
proporcionam além de si mesmas.
Coisas como o dinheiro, que não
têm valor intrínseco,
mas que têm valor instrumental.
E que há coisas que são
valiosas tanto intrínseca
quanto instrumentalmente.
Vocês se lembram do
argumento de Glauco,
1º com a alegação de que
quando falamos de justiça
reivindicamos os seus
benefícios nos termos dos bens
que ela oferece na reputação.
E 2º na história do anel de Giges,
onde ele argumentou que se podemos ir
longe agindo injustamente,
devemos fazê-lo.
E 3º, na história das estátuas
lavadas, ou a história invertida,
em que mesmo não estando
convencido pela história de Giges
– se a justiça produzisse uma má
reputação e a injustiça uma boa –,
você certamente ia querer
agir injustamente.
Assim, esses 3 argumentos são
argumentos de Glauco
a favor da justiça como algo com
valor apenas instrumental.
Na sua imagem,
a justiça é algo com a mesma
utilidade para nós que o dinheiro.
Ela pode nos ajudar a comprar o
nosso caminho para as coisas
que têm valor intrínseco.
O argumento de Sócrates, porém,
é que a justiça possui essas
2 características.
Sem dúvida, é de
utilidade instrumental;
ele não nega os argumentos de
Glauco ou de Adimanto
sobre como ser percebido como justo
pode ser útil para nós.
Mas, além disso,
ele argumenta que há um certo
valor intrínseco associado
a ter uma alma estruturada do modo
que a alma simplesmente é.
Agora, eu quero salientar que, para
ser justo segundo Glauco
e Adimanto, envolve uma trapaça.
Glauco e Adimanto trabalham
com uma noção
subteorizada da justiça.
A imagem que eles têm é de que a
justiça está basicamente em agir
conforme as normas que a
sociedade nos impõe
para sermos considerados
meritosos, falando livremente.
Ser justo é, basicamente,
fazer o que as leis dizem
que você deve fazer.
Sócrates, pelo contrário,
nos fornece um modelo muito mais
sofisticado de justiça.
Mas se essas 2 caracterizações
são o que os filósofos
às vezes gostam de chamar
"extensionalmente equivalente",
então Sócrates não está trapaceando.
Ser extensionalmente equivalente
é escolher o mesmo conjunto
de ações no mundo.
A alegação de Sócrates
é que é uma lei
a que você deve ser honesto e
não matar pessoas.
Mas também alguém com uma
alma estruturada da forma
que ele chamou de "justa" não
roubará, não matará pessoas.
É uma norma da justiça
ter piedade com os pais.
Uma norma da justiça no
sentido convencional.
Assim, também, diz Sócrates,
é uma norma da justiça no sentido de
que ela está caracterizada
que você tenha piedade com os pais.
E assim por diante.
Portanto, o quadro é que
a noção mais completa de justiça
que Sócrates nos proporcionou
concorda com a noção de
justiça que Glauco e Adimanto
estavam interessados, fazendo com
que isso não seja trapacear.
E isso permite a Sócrates
apresentar 2 tipos de argumentos
a favor do valor
intrínseco da justiça.
O 1º está no final do Livro IV,
onde ele alega que a justiça é
uma espécie de saúde.
Basicamente, a justiça é para a alma
como a saúde é para o corpo.
Um corpo saudável é aquele
cujas partes estão fazendo
o que devem fazer.
O seu corpo é saudável se o seu
coração está bombeando sangue
no ritmo certo, de modo que o
seu cérebro receba
a quantidade de oxigênio
necessário e os seus dedos recebam
a quantidade de sangue
necessário, e assim por diante.
Assim como a saúde é de
valor intrínseco
e instrumental no corpo para nós,
a justiça, que é a saúde da alma,
também possui valor intrínseco e
instrumental para nós,
como seres espirituais,
além de físicos.
O espiritual aqui é num
sentido muito modesto.
Então esse é o 1º argumento.
O 1º argumento pressupõe
que há um jeito correto de
funcionamento das pessoas.
E vamos rever isso
no contexto da nossa
discussão de Aristóteles.
Portanto, há uma maneira suposta
do seu corpo funcionar:
O coração deve fazer isto, os
pulmões devem fazer isto, os joelhos
devem fazer isto, os ouvidos devem
fazer isto e assim por diante.
Temos uma imagem do que
equivale a saúde.
Assim, também, diz Platão, o
projeto de escavação
que ele está empenhado em pensar
na analogia cidade-estado
elucida o que seria ser
saudável para uma alma
e revela que a saúde da
alma é ser organizada
na forma dos mandatos da justiça.
Esse é o 1º argumento
oferecido por ele.
É um argumento a partir de algo
que Glauco e Adimanto
admitiram ter utilidade
intrínseca, bem como
instrumental,
e uma alegação de que uma vez que
você entenda o que é a justiça,
você pode ver a analogia direta
entre alma e justiça,
entre corpo e saúde.
O 2º par de argumentos
ocorre no Livro IX
e se preocupa com a felicidade.
Nós voltaremos ao 1º argumento
ao ler John Stuart Mill,
no início da nossa seção
sobre utilitarismo.
E este argumento é o seguinte:
A pessoa que desenvolveu a
capacidade de autorregulação,
a autogovernante,
por causa dos tipos de seres que somos,
já experimentou ao longo do caminho
todos os tipos de prazeres.
De certa forma, é como a
história freudiana.
Começamos como um pacote de desejos
e pegamos as coisas que queremos,
sem considerar as consequências
a longo prazo para nós.
E, ao longo do tempo, colocamos esse
pacote não regulamentado
de necessidades num
determinado tipo de ordem.
Nós o regulamos pela 1ª vez por
meio do louvor e da culpa,
basicamente fazendo uso da
honra de nós mesmos,
e então o regulamos por meio da
reflexão e autoconhecimento.
Assim, a pessoa que conseguiu ter a
sua alma num estado harmonioso
está numa posição
excelente, subjetivamente,
porque ela experimentou
todos os prazeres
que a pessoa que não passa pela
autorregulação experimentou e,
além disso, experimentou os
tipos de prazeres
que estão disponíveis se a nossa
alma está bem-ordenada.
Todos nós experimentamos o prazer
de checar o Facebook e jogar Tetris.
Mas somente alguns de nós já
experimentaram o prazer
de desligar a internet durante a
aula, deixá-la de lado
e escutar o que está sendo
dito pelo professor.
E aqueles que tiveram o grande
prazer de realizar o 2º,
diz Platão, reconheceram
que esse prazer
é uma forma maior de prazer que
o prazer do Angry Birds.
Eu vou deixar a análise desse argumento
a quem já experimentou ambos.
Portanto, este é o 1º argumento
que ele faz no Livro IX.
O 2º argumento é, na verdade, um
argumento muito interessante e,
para ser entendido
completamente, ele exige uma
visita
à alegoria da caverna, que eu
não vou fazer agora.
Basta dizer que ela faz
parte de A República,
e da filosofia de Platão em geral,
e diz que os tipos de prazeres terrenos
que experimentamos na interação com
os objetos são, na verdade,
um certo tipo de prazer irreal.
Eles não estão interagindo
com o que é mais real.
O que é mais real, diz Platão, não
são as aproximações de círculos
que encontramos quando
usamos o PowerPoint Draw
para fazer bonecos de neve no slide.
Eles são os ideais
matemáticos dos círculos.
A verdadeira natureza da
sabedoria, por exemplo,
não é a sabedoria que encontramos
nas pessoas ao nosso redor,
embora ela seja maravilhosa, mas
sim a forma da sabedoria
de que todas essas instâncias são
simplesmente imitações.
Assim, também, com todos os
outros prazeres que temos.
Portanto, há os prazeres terrenos
e há um domínio de coisas com
as quais interagimos
que se encontram além do reino terreno.
Eu passo muito tempo
assistindo a filmes infantis,
sendo mãe de duas crianças.
E entre os filmes que eu vi recentemente
com o meu filho mais novo está Nárnia.
com o meu filho mais velho
está A Origem.
E também vi Matrix
e nós também assistimos ao
O Show de Truman.
Todos esses filmes utilizam
uma ideia de Platão.
A jogada nesses filmes
é que a realidade que você toma como
verdadeira e mais profunda...
o reino terreno, no caso de Nárnia;
a experiência que você está tendo
agora, no caso de Matrix;
e assim por diante...
é, na verdade, apenas uma sombra do
que realmente está além.
E este tema é, de fato, um tema central
de quase todas as
tradições religiosas.
O domínio do secular, o
domínio do mundano,
o domínio do terreno são, de
certa forma, irreal,
e existe, além disso, um
domínio do além,
a interação que fornece um
tipo de satisfação
que é tão imensamente melhor
que as satisfações
de interagir com o mundo, quase não
há comparação entre elas.
E o Sócrates de Platão,
ao dizer que a pessoa com a
alma bem-regulada
gasta o seu tempo
contemplando os formatos,
está fazendo exatamente o mesmo
tipo de alegação que,
por exemplo, um cristão
religioso faria ao dizer
que abrindo mão das
satisfações terrenas
e concentrando-se no que é
espiritualmente valioso,
se ganha uma espécie de possibilidade
de prosperidade incomparável
com a que se pode obter no
domínio terrestre.
Assim, o 2º argumento em
torno da felicidade
reivindica não apenas que a
pessoa com a alma bem-regulada
experimentou todos os prazeres
e sentiu subjetivamente que
isso é o melhor,
mas, na verdade, que esta
pessoa está correta.
Que as melhores formas de prazer
vêm da alma bem-regulada
que gasta o seu tempo interagindo,
não com o mundano e o terreno,
mas com as ideias do além.
Uma citação final.
Uma das maneiras de elucidar o
ponto defendido por Sócrates
é por meio de imagens vívidas.
Vamos encontrar por toda parte, em
cada um dos autores lidos,
que eles estão tentando
propor argumentos
que apelam às várias partes da alma.
Eu apenas forneci um monte de
argumentos que atravessavam
a razão e agora vamos por uma
imagem que deve ser fixada
na sua mente, a ideia a qual Platão
propõe a argumentação.
Aqui está a passagem.
Vocês a leram para hoje:
"É proveitoso a alguém
apoderar-se de ouro injustamente,
se não o puder fazer sem
escravizar ao mesmo tempo
a melhor parte de si mesmo à mais vil?
Certo?
Assim, da parte superior do boneco
de neve à parte inferior.
Aqui está a analogia:
"Se recebesse ouro para entregar como
escravos o filho ou a filha
a senhores selvagens e maus, não
tiraria nenhuma vantagem,
mesmo que recebesse por
isso somas enormes."
Certo?
Se eu dissesse que você pode ter
todo o dinheiro do mundo,
mas tudo que você tem a fazer é
vender seu irmão ou irmã
para a escravidão, presumo que essa
troca não seria atraente
para a maioria de vocês e,
para quem fosse,
saibam que existem cursos sobre
relações entre pares [risos]
no Departamento de Psicologia.
"... não tiraria nenhuma vantagem,
mesmo que recebesse por
isso somas enormes.
Como, então, ele poderia
deixar de ser um miserável
se "escravizar o elemento
mais divino de si mesmo
ao elemento mais ímpio e mais impuro"?
Portanto, a ideia é essa.
Quando você rouba, quando você mata,
quando você age de maneiras que
permitem que a parte inferior
da sua alma faça o que a parte
superior da sua alma
diz que você não deve fazer, você
é exatamente como a pessoa
que tem esses ganhos ilícitos.
Assim como vender o seu filho
ou filha à escravidão
não é uma boa forma de ganhar
dinheiro, Sócrates também sugere
que não é uma boa forma
de ganhar dinheiro
vender a parte superior da sua
alma à escravidão.
Escravizá-la às suas paixões
e aos seus apetites.
Agora, esta ideia de que podemos
pegar um pouco da sabedoria
comum sobre a natureza da felicidade,
mas reconhecer que isso captura
apenas parte da verdade,
é uma das coisas, uma
das muitas coisas,
que está nas passagens de Jonathan
Haidt recomendadas para hoje.
Bom, lemos 2 capítulos para hoje.
Um deles obrigatório, o capítulo 5,
era sobre as teorias
contemporâneas da felicidade.
O 2º, uma recomendação para vocês,
foi o capítulo sobre as virtudes.
Eu quero falar sobre o 1º deles, o
capítulo da felicidade.
Portanto, nós acabamos de ouvir que
Platão aponta, ou argumenta,
ou afirma, a partir deste longo
livro, que a prosperidade humana
não vem da riqueza material e das
satisfações físicas,
mas de algo que seria a
fonte da prosperidade:
reflexão e sabedoria.
E os seus argumentos
fazem uso dos recursos da tradição
da qual ele é uma parte.
Eles estão situados no
contexto grego antigo
e usam as ferramentas
argumentativas da filosofia.
De um jeito similar, a discussão
que Jonathan Haidt oferece
no capítulo 5 tentar fazer
o que faz Platão:
Ela tenta mostrar que há alguma verdade
nas imagens comuns do que a
felicidade equivale,
mas que elas não conseguiram captar
toda a história direito.
E a discussão faz isso, em parte,
usando a estratégia que eu
descrevi anteriormente.
Ela pega a aparência da imagem comum,
oferece uma análise mais
profunda e isso mostra que
são escolhidas basicamente a
mesma classe de coisas.
E Haidt, em particular, nos apresenta a
2 afirmações neste capítulo.
A primeira é aquela que ele chama
de princípio do progresso.
A descoberta – para qual parecem
existir ótimas evidências,
tanto comportamentais quanto
neurocientíficas,
tanto no domínio da cultura
norte-americana quanto multiculturalmente
–
que a maior parte do nosso prazer
não vem da realização
de um objetivo, embora haja algum
prazer que venha daí,
mas do processo de
alcançar esse objetivo.
E a segunda
– que remonta aos materiais que
lemos na semana passada,
de Daniel Kahneman e de
Jonathan Evans –
que, porque somos mais sensíveis a
mudanças nas satisfações
que nos níveis absolutos
de satisfações,
mais de algo nem sempre nos
faz mais felizes.
Mais de algo tende a nos
habituar a esse algo
e fazer com que estejamos
desejosos de mudança,
que é acompanhado por ter
ainda mais disso.
O próximo slide recorre
aos seus clickers,
então se vocês puderem pegá-los...
Não é um slide interessante,
eu apenas peço que vocês tenham
os seus clickers em mãos.
Portanto, isso dá origem a algo
que às vezes é chamado
de esteira hedônica.
A esteira hedônica afirma
que para manter a mesma
quantidade de felicidade,
se ela é baseada nas
satisfações materiais,
precisamos correr para
ficar no mesmo lugar.
E os princípios
psicológicos que
fundamentam
o princípio de adaptação são
exatamente os princípios
que regiam os casos
descritos por Kahneman.
Que somos, como ele mostrou
no sistema visual,
imensamente sensíveis a contrastes
e extremamente ruins em
julgamentos absolutos.
Voltaremos a esse princípio
durante a leitura do artigo de Cass
Sunstein na seção de ética.
OK. Portanto, a pergunta – a
votação está aberta – é:
"Você está pronto para
seguir em frente?"
Pressione 1 se: "Sim, eu mal posso
esperar por Aristóteles."
Pressione 2 se: "Não, eu tenho uma
pergunta sobre Platão ou Haidt."
OK. Então, isto é só
para reativá-los,
no caso de alguma dispersão,
porque eu não paro de falar
e os clickers têm a função de
mantê-los engajados.
OK. Nós temos... Oh, droga.
Este relógio deveria ter
começado automaticamente;
já temos 118 votos.
OK. Então, se você é...
podemos pular isso, não?
Oh! Isso foi pior.
OK. Eu não vou tocar nisso.
Portanto, se você estava na categoria 2
e tem uma pergunta sobre Platão ou
Haidt que gostaria de fazer agora,
por favor, pergunte antes de
descobrirmos o quão raro você é.
Ou, talvez, o quão normal.
Tudo bem.
Nenhuma pergunta?
Pergunta.
Estudante: [inaudível]
Profª. Tamar Gendler: Você
realmente não entendeu sobre
equivalentes extensionais.
Sim.
OK. É um termo de filósofos.
Vamos ver o quão raro você
é e então eu...
Ah, OK. Portanto,
apesar de você estar nos 9%, eu vou
responder a sua pergunta.
As 2 caracterizações são
extensionalmente equivalentes
se elas escolhem o mesmo grupo
de coisas no mundo.
Então, se eu disser: Eu estou
interessado em escolher
as figuras geométricas
que têm 4 cantos,
que são igualmente
espaçadas umas das outras,
e você diz, eu estou interessado em
escolher as figuras geométricas
que têm 4 lados iguais e
ângulos retos,
você está escolhendo quadrados e eu
estou escolhendo quadrados,
mesmo que as descrições
sejam diferentes.
Se eu escolho todos os
irmãos do sexo feminino
e você escolhe todas as
irmãs, estamos escolhendo
a mesma classe de coisas, ainda que
tenham descrições distintas.
OK. Portanto, é uma democracia.
Platão não acha que é a
melhor forma de governo,
mas aqui estamos.
Vamos seguir em frente.
Tudo bem. Aristóteles.
Bom, como vocês estão tendo
uma aula de filosofia,
pelo menos merecem ter esta
imagem explicada.
Vocês a viram em vários
cartazes no campus:
"Venha para o centro de escrita!"
Eu não sei por que eles colocaram
Platão e Aristóteles no
"Venha para o centro de escrita",
mas eu posso contar a vocês
o que ocorre nesta foto.
Portanto, este quadro é
uma pintura famosa
do grande pintor renascentista Rafael.
Chama-se A Escola de Atenas.
Muitas figuras desta pintura
representam amigos do artista.
Você pode ir ao Vaticano para
vê-la, se estiver interessado.
No centro da famosa pintura,
está Platão, de pé bem aqui, e
Aristóteles, bem aqui.
Platão está segurando, quase se pode
ler, um livro chamado Timeu,
um livro de cosmologia, e ele
está apontando para cima,
muitos dizem que ele está
apontando para o reino das formas.
Aristóteles, ao contrário,
está segurando o Ética,
livro que estamos lendo, certo?
O Ética a Nicômaco, aí está.
Você tem um livro que está
na parede do Vaticano.
Isso é tão emocionante.
Você tem uma cópia de US$
6, mas ainda assim...
Você, de certa forma, tem o livro.
E a mão de Aristóteles está
aqui por um dos 2 motivos.
Ou porque ele está apontando
para o domínio terrestre,
como parte de sua negação da
imagem platônica das formas,
ou porque ele está falando
sobre a doutrina do meio,
sobre a qual todos vocês
sabem muita coisa,
porque é a leitura de hoje.
OK. Então, da próxima vez
que virem esta imagem,
pelo menos vão saber que estes
são: Platão e Aristóteles.
Aristóteles, como vocês sabem,
foi aluno de Platão.
E o texto que lemos é, na
minha opinião,
um dos mais profundos trabalhos
de psicologia escritos
nos últimos 2.500 anos.
No entanto, ele é dificílimo
de ler, em parte porque,
embora Aristóteles
escrevesse diálogos,
a maioria destes diálogos
foram perdidos.
E o que temos aqui são,
basicamente, notas da aula
de Aristóteles.
Você percebe isso numa das
páginas em que ele diz:
"e agora vamos olhar para o gráfico."
Certo? Ele tinha – algo como
– uma versão papiro
destes slides do PowerPoint.
Eu não sei se ela era tão animada...
com pessoas andando para
trás e para frente.
Mas o que temos aqui
são notas bastante difíceis de ler.
Por causa disso, em vários aspectos,
ele é o meu livro favorito;
muito do que vai aparecer
no próximo slide
são apenas algumas citações dele
e eu vou contar o que está
acontecendo no texto.
Portanto, este é o Ética
de Aristóteles.
Se para Platão são 30 segundos,
este vai durar 60, por aí.
Vou contar para vocês o que
está acontecendo.
A discussão que lemos começa no
princípio do Livro I,
com um argumento que às
vezes é chamado
de o argumento a favor do summum bonum
– vocês não têm de escrever isso,
por isso não pus no slide –,
às vezes é chamado de bem maior.
Aquilo que é perseguido por
sua própria causa.
E o argumento aqui é basicamente
o que poderíamos chamar
de um argumento de regressão.
É como o argumento do valor
intrínseco/instrumental
que vimos em Platão.
A ideia é que todo o bem, isto
é, tudo o que você busca,
é perseguido tanto por você mesmo
quanto por causa de alguma outra coisa.
E se ele é perseguido por
causa de outra coisa,
deve tocar o fundo ou alcançar o topo.
Summum bonum, o bem supremo:
deve alcançar o topo em alguma coisa.
E a investigação que nos
envolvemos quando fazemos
o que Aristóteles chama de
ciência política...
que não é a ciência política
como no departamento de
Ciência Política,
é a ciência política no sentido
do estudo dos seres
humanos como política,
isto é, animais sociais.
Portanto, o estudo de nós mesmos como
seres socialmente enraizados
é o estudo do que é o bem
maior para o ser humano.
E o bem maior para o ser
humano, diz Aristóteles, é
– tanto na mente do homem comum,
isto é, em algo como o
equivalente à mídia de massa
na Grécia Antiga, quanto na
mente do educado –
o que foi chamado de
eudaimonia ou prosperidade,
às vezes traduzido como felicidade.
Isso é o que todo mundo está buscando.
Então isso é o início das
passagens que lemos do Livro I.
A pergunta é: qual é a coisa
que todo mundo persegue?
E a resposta é: todo mundo está
atrás da mesma coisa.
Eles estão atrás de felicidade,
prosperidade, eudaimonia.
Portanto, a próxima pergunta é:
de que tipo de felicidade?
O que queríamos dizer quando nos
propusemos a buscar a felicidade?
E aqui Aristóteles
atravessa este inventário
de respostas fornecidas.
E vocês perceberão, como bom
aluno de Platão que ele é,
que esta taxonomia soa familiar.
São os prazeres da gratificação?
Ou seja, os prazeres que
Platão chamaria
os prazeres do apetite?
"Não", diz Aristóteles, e ele dá
algumas razões para isso.
São os prazeres da honra?
O que Platão chamaria os
prazeres do espírito?
"Não", diz Aristóteles, e ele dá
algumas razões para isso.
Então são os prazeres da reflexão?
As coisas que vêm da razão?
"Sim!" Diz Aristóteles.
E ele trata de dar algumas
razões para isso.
Mas as razões que ele dá
parecem diferentes das
razões dadas por Platão.
Porque Aristóteles rejeita a
ideia das formas de Platão,
Aristóteles não enfatiza
um domínio além
para defender o seu ponto de vista.
Ele está olhando para um
domínio dentro
para defender o seu ponto de vista.
São 11h17.
Eu vou apresentar mais um
slide e terminamos,
deixando Aristóteles para
a próxima aula.
Então a questão é: se você não
pode se voltar para as formas
como justificação para a razão
– lembrem-se, Platão tem a
seguinte explicação:
"Por que a razão é tão boa?
Ela permite que você se
conecte a um domínio
além de vocês mesmos."
Aristóteles não pode
dar essa resposta.
O que faz, então, a razão tão boa?
Bem, aqui está o argumento.
Cada objeto no mundo, ele
diz, tem uma função.
A função de uma faca é cortar bem.
A função de um peso de papel
é manter os papéis.
A função de um ponteiro laser
é dirigir a atenção para o
slide, e assim por diante.
E um bom exemplar de uma coisa
é aquela que desempenha
bem a sua função.
A sua função é o que a
diferencia de outras entidades.
Os pesos de papel bons são os
que são pesados ??
e os pesos de papel ruins são os
que são leves, ou redondos,
o que faz com que rolem.
Ou invisíveis, de modo que
você não os encontre.
Ou muito pesados,
então você é incapaz de
retirar o papel.
Portanto, quando algo tem uma função,
uma versão boa dessa coisa
se manifesta nela,
o que permite ao objeto executar a sua
função especialmente bem.
Qual é a função dos seres humanos?
Bem, para responder a essa pergunta
temos de responder à questão:
o que é especial sobre
os seres humanos?
O que nos distingue das plantas,
que absorvem nutrição,
e dos animais, que são
capazes de locomoção
e sensação de sentimento?
O que nos distingue desses
seres é a razão.
Assim como as facas são
ótimas quando cortam bem,
os humanos são ótimos quando eles
fazem aquela coisa especial
humana especialmente bem,
quando eles raciocinam bem.
"A razão é – ele
escreve em 1.098 –
a função especial de um ser humano".
O que, então, é o humano bom?
O bom para uma faca é ser o
mais declaradamente
como uma faca, certo?
Quero dizer... todas as espadas mágicas
que você vê em peças de
teatro, filmes e livros?
O que faz delas boas espadas?
Que elas são especialmente capazes de
matar os seus inimigos, certo?
É por isso que as espadas
são boas espadas.
Então, o que faz de você a Espada de
Lancelote dos seres humanos?
É que a sua alma esteja
estruturada de tal forma
que você faça o que é melhor e mais
completo e distintamente humano.
O ser humano bom é aquele que faz
o material humano melhor de
todos, e o material humano
acaba por ser raciocinar e agir
de acordo com a virtude.
Portanto, a questão que voltaremos a
ver na próxima aula é...
e vocês estão em condições de
ler a moral da história –
na verdade, vocês já
deveriam ter lido para hoje:
com o que se parece a virtude
que nos torna distinta
e mais excelentemente humanos
e como ela é cultivada?
Para quinta, leremos 3 textos
realmente fantásticos.
Leremos trechos
selecionados de A Ilíada
e eu dei a vocês 2 opções
de como fazer isso.
Por favor, vejam o guia de leitura.
Vocês podem ler todo o Livro I
ou podem dar uma olhada no contexto
de cada uma das passagens
fornecidas por Jonathan Shay...
e há instruções sobre
como fazer isso.
Leremos o incrível livro de Jonathan
Shay, Achilles in Vietnam,
e também o famoso artigo de
Stanley Milgram, de 1963,
"Behavioral Study of Obedience".
Portanto, começaremos com Aristóteles
e depois debateremos sobre os 3.